longtemps interdite entourée de mystère
l'absinthe fait un retour dans nos
verres depuis quelques années on voit m
d entreprise qui se spécialise dans la
culture de cette plante qui a donné son
nom à l'alcool ou goût herbacées la
recette est une plante vivace recouverte
de poils aux couleurs argentées
certaines poussent naturellement ou
québec mais celles qui intéressent
jonathan doit c'est l'artt émises à
absolution où la grande absente
à maturité elle atteint plus de mètres
de hauteur
celle là jonathan roy doit la cultiver
[Musique]
nous on a choisi d'aller avec la plante
originale qui était utilisé en europe
pour faire la bringue ça poussait
principalement dans les montagnes donc
c'est une plante qui très rustique
[Musique]
depuis 2015 jonathan roy produit un
alcool qu'on appelle aussi accès à cet
art seul dans le bas saint laurent
ce spiritueux est rempli de mystères
surnommée l'île verte en raison de sa
couleur l'acceptent et l'élixir des
peintres comme van gogh et gauguin et
des poètes comme rainbow et baudelaire
on disait de la cent qu'elle rendait fou
et aveugle ceux qui en abusent et la
plante contient une molécule la thuyone
qui auraient des propriétés
hallucinogènes similaire au thc qu'on
retrouve dans le cannabis au canada le
taux de thuyone est limité à 1
milligramme par litre
on est donc bien loin des taux de 250 à
300 mg par litre de l'époque l'artemisia
absolution est facile à cultiver
elle pousse même dans un sol sec et
pauvres
[Musique]
c'est une plante qui résistent super
bien au climat justement on va enlever
la neige sur nos champs qui on va voir
que l'absinthe a déjà commencé à verdir
sous la neige mais il y à un hic
la plante est envahissante c'est des
plans qui sont plutôt difficiles à
contrôler aussitôt qu'on les laisse
monter en graine nos voisins ont des
plans d'absents qui poussent un peu
partout
donc faut être vraiment savoir sur les
semences qui vont pousser dust et de
cette plante là jonathan roy conserve
ses plans quatre ans
les deuxième et troisième années il
récolte les feuilles la quatrième année
il laisse ses plans monté en graine
récoltés elle lui serviront pour
réensemencer séchant une quinzaine de
plantes entre dans la composition de
l'alcool si la grande absente donne
l'amertume à cet alcool la petite
absinthe lui donnent son côté verdâtre
une grosse différence entre la grande
absente la petite absinthe la grande
absente vaut faire des semences pour
faire des graines qui vont être répondu
très facilement alors que la petite
absinthe et plus du drap jeune âge aussi
les racines qui vont crier des nouvelles
tiges puis le chambre s'agrandit a
tranquillement la petite absinthe
souffert un peu plus des sécheresses
c'est une plante qui a besoin d'ombré en
période de sécheresse
donc on le voit un autre champ de petite
absinthe loïc de l'ombre les plans sont
beaucoup plus haut hello c'est plein
soleil c'est un peu plus de difficultés
jonathan juin est au des rares
distillateur à cultiver toutes les
plantes qui entre dans la composition de
l'absinthe souffle à nice qui ne peut
pousser ici en raison du climat
en cultivant toutes ces aromates
il s'assure de la fraîcheur de ses
produits
non
on cultive ce qu'on peut voir en avant
ici skis en arrière c'est l'équivalent
mais acheter de façon industrielle le
goût rien à voir souvent avec les
aromates qu'on veut cultiver une ou même
une bon exemple c'est le carvi ce qu'on
peut trouver dans les épiceries ses fans
ça coûte pas grand chose on peut retirer
un petit goût quand est ce qu'on va
cultiver nous mêmes
c'est une explosion de saveurs embauché
vraiment délicieux
des bus ou les plans ont poussé au stock
on voit qu'il goûte on commence à se
former on veut couper le chant la petite
absinthe aussi effet prêtes à être
récoltées
quand le gros chaleur vont être pas mal
fini on va commencer à voir que la
petite absinthe doit se préparer pour
l'hiver les feuilles du bois vont
commencer à journée c'est là qu'on va
récolter dans les années de sécheresse
on veut récolter plus tôt pour éviter
que les plantes sèches directement sur
le sur la tige
[Musique]
une fois coupée et demi en ballots les
plans sont suspendus pour y être séchés
puis ils sont effeuiller
[Musique]
la production de l'alcool peut alors
commencer le processus s'échelonne sur
plusieurs jours première étape la
macération
pendant quatre jours les feux de la
grande absinthe pour macérer dans de
l'eau avec des graines de fenouil et
d'alice puis les alambics sont remplies
et trois corps avec de l'alcool pur
ils sont chauffés c'est le processus de
la distillation qui dure une douzaine
d'heures une fois la distillation
complété jonathan roy obtient une
absinthe clair elle sera coloris dans
les cuves en mai 1 72 % d'alcool par
volume en bouteille pour partenaire la
coloration de l'absinthe la petite
absinthe l'hysope lamente la mélisse
donne la couleur à l'alcool comme le
taux de chlorophylle 20 lits dans les
plantes d'une année à l'autre
jonathan roy doit ajuster sa recette il
doit 12 essais aromates pour obtenir la
couleur désirée
un vert lime qui évolue aussi dans le
temps
étant donné qu'on utilise des plantes ça
va suivre le même cycle qu'une feuille
dans un arbre fraîchement accueilli une
feuille va être ouverte à l'automne ça
va virer un peu plus jaune
éventuellement ça va arriver vers le
rouge art et la fin de la vie de la
feuille et elle va devenir brune donc
ici on a une absinthe fraîchement didier
qu'on peut voir la coloration est un
beau vert lime ici on a une bouteille
qui provient de notre première
d'initiation 2016 et on peut voir que la
coloration inchangé actuellement les
fils du roi produisent trois mille six
cents bouteilles d'accès tahar hani
c'est une petite production mais en
menant seulement les ventes de cet
alcool à nice et ont progressé entre 10
et 15%
jonathan roy vient d'acquérir une
nouvelle machine automatisée de
remplissage de ses bouteilles
un engouement présentement pour les
produits à nice et l'absinthe en général
oui on commence à revoir de l'absinthe
dans plusieurs bars un peu partout au
québec
l'absinthe et quand on peut plus arrêter
je n'attends voix n'a pas fini
d'explorer tout le potentiel que lui
réserve cet alcool l'absinthe est un
très beau spiritueux pour ajouter des
aromates rajouter des serveurs dans
l'absinthe qui permettrait d'avoir un
nouvel essor au nouvel engouement pour
interdite dans plusieurs pays européens
et pendant un siècle la production a
repris progressivement mais elle est
réglementée
l'absinthe n'a jamais été bannie au
canada mais elle était introuvable
son passé trouble semble donc s'estomper
aujourd'hui certains d'ici à tort se
lance dans la production d'absinthe
elle demeure marginale mais elle
progresse lentement